Lucia: 做出了水母灯他也亮不了
Lucia: We made a jellyfish lamp, but it doesn't light up.
Lucia: 但我们可以认为他是一个水母
Lucia: But we can consider it a jellyfish.
Lucia: 没有灯
Lucia: Without the lamp.
Lucia: 去掉灯字
Lucia: Remove the word "lamp".
Jake:就拿手电筒照一照
Jake: Just shine a flashlight on it.
Lucia: 也可以理论上说比如说像这样
Lucia: You could also theoretically say, like this.
Lucia: 我觉得这个瓶子就还行
Lucia: I think this bottle works fine.
Lucia: 他这要是弧度更就是slope
Lucia: If its curve was more, like, the slope...
Lucia: 更陡一点就好了
Lucia: Steeper, it would be better.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:你把它放起来吧
Alice: You should put it away.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Just...
Lucia: 本来应该在这里面放一个那种小灯珠
Lucia: Originally, we should have put a small bulb in here.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 算了，it doesn't matter
Lucia: Forget it, it doesn't matter.
Jake:那是得像那种
Jake: It should be like those...
Jake:呃那叫啥呢
Jake: Uh, what's it called...
Jake:苏打水
Jake: Soda water.
Jake:或者可以买
Jake: Or you can buy...
Jake:其实就是很品的那种
Jake: Actually, it's like those fancy ones.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:是果汁那种
Jake: Like fruit juice.
Lucia: 就是圆一点的就
Lucia: Just make it rounder.
Lucia: 呃怎么说呢就是网上那种
Lucia: Uh, how to say it, like the ones online.
Jake:你觉得圆可乐吗
Jake: Do you mean round cola?
Lucia: 就是废物利用的那种教程
Lucia: Like those DIY tutorials.
Lucia: 他用的是那种奶茶盖的可乐瓶
Lucia: They use milk tea lids on cola bottles.
Lucia: 可乐瓶那个应该也还行
Lucia: Cola bottles should work too.
Lucia: 元我觉得元气森林那个弧度就还不错
Lucia: I think the curve of the Genki Forest bottle is pretty good.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Just, just...
Lucia: 我们如果用小瓶子做的话
Lucia: If we use small bottles...
Lucia: 它就会比较小
Lucia: It will be smaller.
Lucia: 元气森林我觉得这就还可以
Lucia: I think the Genki Forest one is fine.
Lucia: 剪到这个位置
Lucia: Cut it to this position.
Alice:我决定给我的狗做几个
Alice: I decided to make a few for my dog.
Alice:这样带个花
Alice: With a flower like this.
Alice:不是白的
Alice: Not just white.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈就是这样
Alice: Hahaha, just like this.
Alice:给它围个
Alice: Wrap it up...
Jake:那就戴一下呗
Jake: Then just wear it.
Alice:是弄这几朵呢还是给他弄个 对
Alice: Should we put these few flowers on or make it a... right.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: \花环
Lucia: ...flower crown.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:我们是没有透明胶带啊
Alice: We don't have any transparent tape, do we?
Lucia: 好像是没有
Lucia: Seems like we don't.
Alice:那种胶带也可以
Alice: That kind of tape will work too.
Lucia: 这好像是我昨天压那个花
Lucia: This seems like the flower I pressed yesterday.
Lucia: 压一天能压压成型吗
Lucia: Will pressing it for a day make it take shape?
Lucia: 有点想打开看看但是
Lucia: I kinda want to open and check, but...
Alice:哎昨天那个白色的胶带还在
Alice: Hey, the white tape from yesterday is still here.
Alice:是不是后来又在对对对
Alice: Did we use it later, right, right, right.
Lucia: 双面胶那可能健康拿走了吧
Lucia: The double-sided tape, maybe Health took it?
Alice:就先用这个吧
Alice: Let's just use this for now.
Lucia: 我们中午吃什么呀卤煮
Lucia: What are we having for lunch? Lu Zhu?
Alice:卤煮
Alice: Lu Zhu.
Alice:双面胶
Alice: Double-sided tape.
Lucia: 它是一种类似于冒菜的东西吗
Lucia: Is it something like hotpot?
Lucia: 它不是
Lucia: It's not?
Alice:做法上可能是近亲
Alice: Maybe it's a close relative in cooking style.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:怎么没有胶呢
Alice: Why don't we have any tape?
Alice:剪刀也找不到
Alice: Can't find the scissors either.
Lucia: 这真的啊好难掰啊
Lucia: This is really hard to break apart!
Lucia: AI 你看掰这种水果需要策略你学会了吗
Lucia: AI, you see, breaking this fruit needs strategy, have you learned it?
Lucia: 哎呀喂你学废了吗
Lucia: Oh my, have you mastered it?
Lucia: 他没有
Lucia: He hasn't.
Alice:小狗狗的鼻子小狗狗的嘴
Alice: Little puppy's nose, little puppy's mouth.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
其他人：拜拜拜
Others: Bye bye bye.
Lucia: 我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Lucia: 不行不能拔这个
Lucia: No, I can't unplug this.
Lucia: 这连着是连摄像头的啊
Lucia: This is connected to the camera.
Lucia: let me check
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: Mmm hmm hmm.
Lucia: 哦对我还有一个快递到了对
Lucia: Oh right, I have a package that arrived.
Lucia: 给那个
Lucia: For that.
Lucia: 发一下
Lucia: Send it out.
Lucia: 哎呀我的芍药终于想开了
Lucia: Oh my peonies have finally bloomed.
Lucia: 不知道这个
Lucia: Not sure if the
Lucia: 不知道水里的营养
Lucia: nutrients in the water
Lucia: 够不够支撑到他想开
Lucia: are enough to support their blooming.
Lucia: 哼
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 感觉我们退房的时候
Lucia: I feel like when we check out
Lucia: 收拾这个房子会是个大工程
Lucia: cleaning up this place will be a huge task.
Alice:你买回家的票了吗
Alice: Have you bought your ticket home?
Lucia: 嗯还没
Lucia: Not yet.
Lucia: 不过票挺多的
Lucia: But there are plenty of tickets.
Lucia: 应该我回去
Lucia: I think I'll go back.
Lucia: 要不然就坐高铁回去
Lucia: Or maybe I'll take the high-speed train back.
Lucia: 行我来的时候是坐的
Lucia: Yeah, I took
Lucia: 我来的时候坐的飞机
Lucia: I took a plane when I came here.
Shure: 你们分开马上就开忙了吗
Shure: Will you start working right after you split up?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 忙完这个就开忙了吗
Shure: Will you start working right after this?
Lucia: 就忙什么
Lucia: Start working on what?
Lucia: 我们现在
Lucia: What are we
Lucia: 我们现在在忙什么啊
Lucia: What are we busy with right now?
Shure: 就是我说就是
Shure: I mean like
Lucia: 你说项目结束之后
Lucia: You mean after the project ends?
Lucia: 嗯我应该暂时在北京
Lucia: I think I'll stay in Beijing for a while.
Lucia: 没什么事
Lucia: Not much to do.
Lucia: 本来想着可能会有点事
Lucia: I thought there might be something
Lucia: 但是最近两天我看了下
Lucia: but looking at the past two days
Lucia: 好像不太需要继续待在这
Lucia: it seems like there's no need to stay here.
Alice:嗯咋了
Alice: Hmm, what's up?
Lucia: 要聚餐吗哈哈
Lucia: Are we having a dinner party? Haha.
Shure: 考虑点大的
Shure: Think of something bigger.
Alice:比如说
Alice: Like what?
Lucia: for example
Lucia: For example.
Shure: 三亚的房子他妈太便宜了
Shure: Houses in Sanya are so cheap.
Shure: 一天200啊
Shure: Only 200 a day.
Alice:嗯大理也便宜
Alice: Yeah, Dali is cheap too.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:大理就是一整个民宿
Alice: You can get a whole guesthouse in Dali.
Lucia: 我可以啊
Lucia: I’m up for it.
Lucia: 我没啥事
Lucia: I have nothing going on.
Lucia: 因为我现在是该片
Lucia: Because right now, it's about time.
Lucia: 所以只不过我就是
Lucia: So it's just that I...
Lucia: 因为我家在西安
Lucia: Because my home is in Xi'an...
Lucia: 我就是我毕业的
Lucia: I just graduated...
Lucia: 所以我现在
Lucia: So now I...
Lucia: 对所以我现在就是就平常不在北京
Lucia: Yeah, so now I just usually don't stay in Beijing...
Lucia: 所以假如说不是急急客
Lucia: So if it's not an urgent thing...
Lucia: 连着就要搞那个什么的话
Lucia: And there's something going on continuously...
Lucia: 我就需要先回一下家
Lucia: I need to go back home first...
Lucia: 不然还在北京租房子麻烦的很
Lucia: Otherwise, it's really troublesome to rent a place in Beijing...
Lucia: 我到今年
Lucia: Until this year...
Alice:去三亚有什么规划吗
Alice: Do you have any plans for Sanya?
Shure: 昨天晚上
Shure: Last night...
Shure: 是他让我破房
Shure: He told me to break the house...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 破房
Lucia: Break the house?
Tasha: 我又让你破房了
Tasha: I made you break the house again?
Shure: 你让我楼板破房
Shure: You made me break the floor...
Lucia: 哈哈薇薇让所有人破房了
Lucia: Haha, Tasha made everyone break the house...
Shure: 怎么不满了
Shure: How unsatisfied...
Tasha: 是的我让杨老板也破房
Tasha: Yes, I made Jake break the house too...
Shure: 站你旁边碍你眼了是吗
Shure: Standing next to you annoys you, huh?
Katrina: 哈哈我要摔碟子骂人了
Katrina: Haha, I'm going to break dishes and curse people...
Lucia: 我想问一下他破什么房了
Lucia: I want to ask what house he broke?
Lucia: 姚老板青青的破房了
Lucia: Jake broke the house too...
Shure: 有没有可能
Shure: Is it possible...
Shure: 嗯有没有可能
Shure: Hmm, is it possible...
Lucia: 那边10天只要2,000块钱大别墅
Lucia: There, a big villa for just 2,000 yuan for 10 days...
Lucia: 这么便宜
Lucia: So cheap...
Alice:那大一个月才只要1,000多呢
Alice: That big one is just over 1,000 a month...
Tasha: 但是老板离那个新加坡近
Tasha: But Jake is closer to Singapore...
其他人：但是他是新加坡飞到三亚只要3小时
Others: But it's just a 3-hour flight from Singapore to Sanya...
Lucia: 只要30块钱哦三我
Lucia: Only 30 yuan, oh my...
Alice:3小时
Alice: 3 hours...
其他人：他是先飞到上海，再从上海飞到北京
Others: He flies to Shanghai first, then from Shanghai to Beijing...
Lucia: 他是转的机啊缩嘎
Lucia: He had a layover, I see...
Alice:浅浅破防了
Alice: He broke down a bit...
Alice:那这个房间呢
Alice: And this room...
Tasha: 2000 一天
Tasha: 2000 a day...
Alice:一天
Alice: A day?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah...
其他人：一天，1300
Alice:啊 1,300一天
Lucia: 1300 这么贵
其他人：1500好像是
Lucia:  这么贵
Alice:1,500一天
Tasha: 他说用了2万
Lucia: 好贵哦
其他人：对算押金哦
Tasha: 哦算押金
Tasha: 破房
其他人：之前挑个更贵了，没去了
其他人：那个不太好，那个
Alice:丢盔弃甲破大房了
Lucia: 可能因为是北京的缘故吧
其他人：反正这些天这个已经算还可以了
Tasha: 已经决定转战三亚了他们
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: 刚好我没去过三亚
Lucia: 如果你们到时候那个啥的话
Lucia: 可以我可以
Lucia: Sure, I can.
Lucia: 我可以再去玩
Lucia: I can go play again.
Lucia: 我今年8月份之前应该都有空
Lucia: I should be free until August this year.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 这个逼别搞不起来啊  我考
Shure: Don't mess this up, damn.
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 这他妈网络问题
Shure: It's a damn network issue.
Jake:仨给抢了呀
Jake: They snatched all three.
Jake:哎不行啊
Jake: No, it's not working.
Jake:为了10年之后的10个亿
Jake: For the 1 billion in 10 years.
Alice:你怎么了微微
Alice: What's wrong, Tasha?
Tasha: 好酸
Tasha: So sour.
Jake:对必须搞
Jake: Yeah, we have to do it.
Alice:你说你弄的啥呀
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:今天必须搞
Jake: It has to be done today.
Lucia: 10个小目标
Lucia: 10 small goals.
Tasha: 他楼上冲的黑咖啡
Tasha: He made black coffee upstairs.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 发行150个，我自己偷偷血藏50个。
Shure: Release 150, and I'll secretly keep 50.
Katrina: 这是在干什么
Katrina: What's going on here?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, oh hahaha
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh oh oh
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Alice:咖啡可以苦不能酸
Alice: Coffee can be bitter but not sour
Lucia: 咖啡可以苦不能酸
Lucia: Coffee can be bitter but not sour
Lucia: 是的你加点奶吧
Lucia: Yeah, add some milk
Lucia: 我头好疼啊
Lucia: My head hurts
Lucia: 啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's nothing
Lucia: 可能是打针的问题
Lucia: Maybe it's from the injection
Jake:花多少钱啊
Jake: How much did it cost?
Shure: 这个这应该抓好要化一点点小
Shure: This, this should be grabbed well, spend a little bit
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:他这有墙吗你这有墙吗
Jake: Does he have a wall? Do you have a wall?
Jake:你这翻吗
Jake: Do you flip it?
Tasha: 杨老板
Tasha: Jake
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 我们今天要再采购一次
Tasha: We need to shop again today
Tasha: 然后再做甜品
Tasha: And then make desserts
Tasha: 牛奶也没了
Tasha: We're out of milk too
Jake:那就买呗
Jake: Then just buy it
Tasha: 那是去超市还是直接手机上买
Tasha: Should we go to the supermarket or just buy it online?
Lucia: 你这个单子好好看呀
Lucia: Your list looks great
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think
Jake:一会问一下大家有没有别的要买
Jake: Let's ask everyone if they need anything else
Jake:或者比方说你没到的东西
Jake: Or, for example, things you didn't get
Jake:如果多的话直接出去买
Jake: If there's a lot, we'll go out and buy
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure
Jake:去超市买
Jake: Go to the supermarket
Jake:威亚还有什么没到的东西吗
Jake: Tasha, is there anything else that hasn't arrived?
Lucia: 我的欧根纱和一个就是镭射反光纸
Lucia: My organza and a reflective laser paper
Lucia: 不知道我们可以在外面多逛逛
Lucia: Maybe we can stroll around outside
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see
Lucia: 如果如果时间允许
Lucia: If time allows
Jake:这可以商量商量时间
Jake: We can discuss the timing
Jake:看看时间不多了
Jake: It seems we don't have much time
Lucia: 这明天明天活动的话
Lucia: If there's an event tomorrow
Lucia: 我们是不是得把这俩客厅收拾收拾
Lucia: Should we tidy up these two living rooms?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 见不得人哈
Tasha: Not fit for public view, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我们这个客厅现在状态
Lucia: Our living room right now...
Lucia: 会不会过于真实了
Lucia: Is it too realistic?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:压花怎么说
Jake: How do we deal with the pressed flowers?
Jake:我们压花现在是什么
Jake: What's the status of our pressed flowers?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina: 压完了压完了哦
Katrina: They're done pressing.
Lucia: 昨天的压花可以取了吗
Lucia: Can we take out yesterday's pressed flowers?
Katrina: 里面有蜜蜂哎
Katrina: There are bees inside.
Lucia: 哎没有
Lucia: No, there aren't.
Lucia: 我刚打开的
Lucia: I just opened it.
Katrina: 我们去把它晒一会太阳应该
Katrina: We should let them sunbathe for a while.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 好的但
Lucia: Alright, but...
Katrina: 但是昨天下午才压应该还不够
Katrina: They were only pressed yesterday afternoon, so it's probably not enough time.
Lucia: 那行那再晒一会
Lucia: Fine, let's sun them a bit longer.
Lucia: 我刚才就是把它打开之后
Lucia: After I just opened them,
Lucia: 在想能不能就是整个拆开
Lucia: I was thinking about completely dismantling them.
Lucia: 但我又不敢
Lucia: But I didn't dare.
Lucia: 所以我又没拆
Lucia: So I didn't.
Jake:然后这些花是放回卧室是吗还是搁这
Jake: Then should we put these flowers back in the bedroom or leave them here?
Katrina: 可以放回卧室
Katrina: We can put them back in the bedroom.
Lucia: 可以放回卧室吧
Lucia: Let's put them back in the bedroom.
Jake:那就放回卧室吧
Jake: Alright, back to the bedroom then.
Katrina: 今天等一会下午看一下有没有压
Katrina: Let's check again this afternoon if they're pressed.
Katrina: 好的有的
Katrina: Okay, we will.
Katrina: 那个花瓣可能就好了
Katrina: The petals should be ready.
Katrina: 就可以自己做
Katrina: We can make them ourselves.
Katrina: 就明信片
Katrina: Like postcards.
Jake:那我们先把这个花给放回去
Jake: Let's put these flowers back first.
Jake:让客厅看起来东西少一点
Jake: Make the living room look a bit less cluttered.
Katrina: 好不容易啊
Katrina: Finally!
Alice:自己的屋里
Alice: In your own room.
Jake:自个卧室
Jake: In your own bedroom.
Katrina: Lisa居然开始发布命令
Katrina: Lisa's starting to give orders now.
Katrina: 给他放在阳光底下怎么样
Katrina: How about we put them under the sunlight?
Lucia: 可
Lucia: Okay
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 追求卓越
Lucia: Pursue excellence
Lucia: 书写未来
Lucia: Write the future
Katrina: 我靠追求卓越是我们校训
Katrina: Oh my gosh, "pursue excellence" is our school motto.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: That scared me.
Lucia: 是你高中的校训吗
Lucia: Is that your high school motto?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No
Katrina: 我们大学校训就是什么追求卓越
Katrina: Our university motto is something like "pursue excellence".
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Katrina: 做我的手工
Katrina: Doing my crafts.
Lucia: 这是谢冰竹的烟
Lucia: These are Xie Bingzhu's cigarettes.
Lucia: 是吧我可要偷偷抽一根哈
Lucia: Right? I'm going to sneak one, okay?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm
Lucia: 哈会吗
Lucia: Haha, can I?
Katrina: 你会吗不是很会
Katrina: Can you? Not really.
Lucia: 不是很会
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 能抽起来但是不是很会
Lucia: I can light it, but I'm not good at it.
Katrina: 哇你怎么会抽的
Katrina: Wow, how did you learn to smoke?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我朋友会抽哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, my friend smokes, haha.
Katrina: 别人教你的嘛
Katrina: Someone taught you?
Katrina: 好好
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 大家到后来都变成烟酒独占的人了
Katrina: Everyone ends up becoming a smoker and drinker in the end.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 把花拿走是吧
Katrina: Take the flowers away, right?
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Sure
Katrina: 清一下桌子
Katrina: Clean the table.
Lucia: 这好像是我的
Lucia: This seems to be mine.
Lucia: 我想给他换换水可以换吗
Lucia: I want to change the water for him, can I?
Lucia: 换了他不会他不会他不会嘎吧
Lucia: If I change it, it won't, it won't, it won't die, right?
Alice:他是自然的老去
Alice: It will naturally age.
Lucia: 那我到洗手间去换啊
Lucia: Then I'll change it in the bathroom.
Alice:我到洗手间
Alice: I'm going to the bathroom.
Lucia: 您在切芒果
Lucia: You're cutting a mango.
Jake:呀
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 让我们看看今天的转化率有多少
Lucia: Let's see the conversion rate for today.
Jake:好称一下
Jake: Okay, weigh it.
Lucia: 啊在这
Lucia: Ah, it's here.
Jake:哈哈好嘞
Jake: Haha, alright.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Shure: 那个拿一个包躲在我这屋干什么呢
Shure: What are you doing hiding in my room with a bag?
Lucia: 我给您清好铃了
Lucia: I cleared the bell for you.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 你可以先把盘子放在上面
Lucia: You can put the plate on top first.
Lucia: 然后清一下铃然后再称它
Lucia: Then clear the bell and weigh it again.
Lucia: 就是要把这些拿起来
Lucia: Just need to take these off.
Lucia: 我已经学会了薇薇如何使用这个秤
Lucia: I've learned how to use this scale from Tasha.
Lucia: 就是这好像有点有点有点不平
Lucia: But it seems a bit, a bit uneven.
Lucia: 我们还是在这里吧
Lucia: Let's do it here.
Jake:对就在这就在这
Jake: Yes, right here.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 就是您可以先把这个盘子放上来
Lucia: You can put the plate on first.
Lucia: 然后把芒果拿走看一下
Lucia: Then take the mango off and check.
Lucia: 哇这盘子这么重
Lucia: Wow, this plate is so heavy.
Jake:哎我好像有快递
Jake: Hey, I think I got a delivery.
Lucia: 青柠嗯好
Lucia: Lime, okay.
Lucia: 然后哎您又碰到了
Lucia: Then, oh, you touched it again.
Jake:我有快递到了
Jake: My delivery arrived.
Shure: 这会有实习价值是吗到
Shure: This has internship value, right?
Lucia: 嗯又有快递到了
Lucia: Hmm, another delivery.
Jake:呃应该是外卖驴肉火烧
Jake: Uh, it should be donkey meat sandwiches.
Lucia: 啊OK OK
Lucia: Ah, OK OK.
Jake:没吃过卤煮
Jake: Never had braised pork.
Lucia: 没有真没有
Lucia: No, never.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哎你好哎你好外卖到
Jake: Hey, hello, your delivery is here.
Jake:了哎好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: It's here, it's here, it's here, it's here.
Lucia: （歌声）
Lucia: (singing)
Jake:你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you?
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 这么高级吗
Shure: So fancy.
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Ouch.
Lucia: 哎呀， 这个沾水就掉了
Lucia: Oh no, it comes off with water.
Shure: 那个西直门那个吗
Shure: The one in Xizhimen?
Katrina: 西什么我不知道
Katrina: Xi what? I don't know.
Shure: 西直门
Shure: Xizhimen.
Katrina: 反正就你们学校走出来一会就到了
Katrina: Anyway, it's just a short walk from your school.
Shure: 我每次都去那个
Shure: I go there every time.
Shure: 西直门那个
Shure: That place in Xizhimen
Katrina: 只是因为我今天睡饱了
Katrina: Just because I got enough sleep today
Katrina: 我今天没定闹钟
Katrina: I didn't set an alarm today
Katrina: 因为我看昨天晚上没有说今天几点
Katrina: Because I saw that last night, they didn't say what time today
Katrina: 说还是很怪
Katrina: It's still very weird to say
Shure: 问其他的一律不答
Shure: Don't answer any other questions
Shure: 吃饭吗吃哈哈哈
Shure: Wanna eat? Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈对你总觉得好到位
Katrina: Hahaha, yeah, you always feel it's just right
Shure: （歌声）那里春风沉醉
Shure: (Singing) Where the spring breeze is intoxicating
Jake:来负责一下
Jake: Come on, take responsibility
Jake:分一分
Jake: Distribute it
Katrina: 点的什么呀
Katrina: What did you order?
Jake:这个他路上撒了卤煮
Jake: This, he spilled some braised meat on the way
Jake:撒的很
Jake: Spilled a lot
Jake:可以撒的很卤煮越来越看越想吃了
Jake: It can be spilled a lot, braised meat looks more and more appetizing
Tasha: 懂了
Tasha: Got it
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 这其实
Shure: This actually
Lucia: 所以他是一种冒菜吗是
Lucia: So is it a kind of spicy hotpot?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Shure: no no no这卤煮闻着下水味就有点重
Shure: No no no, this braised meat has a strong offal smell
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Katrina: 下一轮全战争
Katrina: Next round, all-out war
Jake:下水味重是吧
Jake: The offal smell is strong, right?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Lucia: 什么他里面是下水吗
Lucia: What, is there offal inside?
Lucia: 不是他是用下水做的吗
Lucia: No, is it made with offal?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:就是硬煮
Jake: It's just hard-boiled
Lucia: 硬煮
Lucia: Hard-boiled
Jake:就是煮啊煮煮煮直接煮
Jake: Just boil it, boil, boil, directly boil
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay
Shure: 这其实
Shure: This actually
Shure: 分两个人分吃吧
Shure: Split it between two people
Shure: 或者三个人
Shure: Or three people
Shure: 或者自己每个人拿个小碗接着吃吧
Shure: Or each person just take a small bowl and keep eating
Jake:  拿小碗接着吃
Jake: Take a small bowl and keep eating
Shure: 拿小碗接着吃
Shure: Take a small bowl and keep eating
Shure: 对行
Shure: Yeah, that's good
Jake:你多整点小碗我找不着碗
Jake: Get more small bowls, I can't find any.
Shure: 行那去楼下吃楼上吃
Shure: Okay, let's eat downstairs or upstairs.
Lucia: 呃我看一下楼下的桌子
Lucia: Uh, let me check the table downstairs.
Lucia: 现在情况怎么样
Lucia: How's the situation now?
Lucia: 应该大家都把
Lucia: Everyone should have...
Jake:很不怎么样哈哈哈哈哦这样
Jake: It's not great, hahaha. Oh, like this.
Lucia: 呃不是大家都把花搬走了吗
Lucia: Didn't everyone move the flowers?
Lucia: 还有一瓶
Lucia: There's one more bottle.
Jake:好我开始切了
Jake: Okay, I'll start cutting.
Lucia: 这好像是您的吧
Lucia: This seems to be yours.
Jake:我不是我的
Jake: No, it's not mine.
Lucia: 啊不是是修硕的
Lucia: Ah, it's Shure's then.
Jake:给他放过去
Jake: Give it to him.
Lucia: 哦对我还没有称这个
Lucia: Oh right, I haven't weighed this yet.
Lucia: 咦这芒果好热呀
Lucia: Eh, this mango is so warm.
Jake:把这个给修硕窗台
Jake: Give this to Shure on the windowsill.
Tasha: 是在二楼吃吗
Tasha: Are we eating on the second floor?
Tasha: 哎吃饭的呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the food?
Lucia: 这芒果有85.8克
Lucia: This mango weighs 85.8 grams.
Jake:这么重哎呦
Jake: That's so heavy, wow.
Tasha: 你要开始转换率了吗
Tasha: Are you going to start converting?
Lucia: 你要开始转化率了吗
Lucia: Are you going to start converting?
Lucia: 对不是是杨老板要开始转化他了
Lucia: Yes, no, Jake is going to start converting it.
Alice:干嘛呀
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:我要转化他吃
Jake: I'm going to convert it to food.
Tasha: 吃饭吗
Tasha: To eat?
Alice:啊要干嘛
Alice: Ah, what are you doing?
Jake:吃卤煮
Jake: Eating braised pork.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:上楼吃卤煮
Jake: Eat braised pork upstairs.
Tasha: 你骗我
Tasha: You're lying to me.
Alice:你
Alice: You...
Jake:啊还有火烧
Jake: Ah, there's still huoshao.
Jake:火烧有奶了
Jake: Houshao with milk.
Jake:我还得出去一趟
Jake: I need to go out again.
Tasha: 行我不吃卤煮
Tasha: Okay, I won't eat braised pork.
Lucia: 你要转化他干嘛
Lucia: Why do you want to convert it?
Alice:要转化他干嘛
Alice: Why convert it?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Lucia: 我们那天那个啥
Lucia: Remember that day when...
Lucia: 做甜点的时候闹着玩了
Lucia: We were messing around while making desserts.
Lucia: 就是说看那一个芒
Lucia: We were seeing how much...
Lucia: 果能削出多少来
Lucia: Mango we could peel off.
Tasha: 肉
Tasha: The flesh.
Lucia: 对不是
Lucia: Yeah, but no...
Lucia: 是因为金康他头一回削的时候
Lucia: It was because Jin Kang was peeling for the first time.
Tasha: 边吃边削
Tasha: Peeling and eating at the same time.
Lucia: 但是对就这个芒果他皮比较粘肉
Lucia: And this mango had a lot of flesh sticking to the skin.
Lucia: 所以他削开
Lucia: So when he peeled it...
Lucia: 不是本来就很小吗
Lucia: It was already very small, right?
Lucia: 然后好多肉都粘在那个皮上
Lucia: And a lot of flesh stuck to the skin.
Lucia: 对对然后然后听他说这怎么回事
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, then he said, what's going on?
Lucia: 我说正确打开方式是把那个皮剥开
Luci
Lucia: 然后把它吃掉
Alice:然后把这样滑到的啊
Lucia: 不是就我们就把那个皮上粘的都吃了
Lucia: 对所以我们就说
Lucia: 测测这转化率到底能有多少
Lucia: 这谁画的丁老头
Alice:嗯
Lucia: 哪个是丁老头
Lucia: Which one is Old Ding?
Alice:哪个是丁老头
Alice: Which one is Old Ding?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 不也不算丁老头
Lucia: No, not really Old Ding.
Lucia: 他跟丁老头是类似的画法
Lucia: He draws similarly to Old Ding.
Lucia: 好像就那种有个顺口溜画他
Lucia: It's like there's a rhyme about him.
Alice:啊什么
Alice: What?
Alice:一个丁老头
Alice: An Old Ding?
Lucia: 对捡了两个蛋什么的
Lucia: Yeah, picking up two eggs or something.
Lucia: 我需要一个
Lucia: I need one.
Lucia: 充电宝
Lucia: A power bank.
Lucia: 让我看看他这有没有
Lucia: Let me see if he has one.
Lucia: 我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Lucia: 没有了是吧
Lucia: There aren't any, right?
Jake:没有了是吧
Jake: There aren't any, right?
Tasha: what's this煎饼果子
Tasha: What's this? Jianbing Guozi?
Lucia: 没看到那个太大了
Lucia: I didn't see it, it's too big.
Lucia: 我这裙子没有口袋
Lucia: My skirt doesn't have pockets.
Jake:太大了这个
Jake: This is too big.
Alice:火烧
Alice: It's burning.
Jake:这个可能还行
Jake: This might be okay.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Lucia: 这是充电宝啊
Lucia: It's a power bank.
Jake:这是充电宝啊
Jake: It's a power bank.
Lucia: 对你可以试试
Lucia: Yeah, you can try it.
Jake:对你可以试试你插上之后过一会看看
Jake: Yeah, you can try it. Plug it in and check after a while.
Lucia: OK你插上之后过一会看看
Lucia: OK, plug it in and check after a while.
Jake:他正在充电对
Jake: It's charging now.
Lucia: 试试看我好像把线放在这
Lucia: Try it out. I think I left the cable here.
Tasha: 吃饭了
Tasha: Time to eat.
Lucia: 是我的吗
Lucia: Is it mine?
Shure: 可以上去吃
Shure: You can go upstairs to eat.
Lucia: 是我的good
Lucia: Is it mine? Good.
Shure: 准备吃上去
Shure: Get ready to go up and eat.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
Tasha: 我我要转化
Tasha: I need to convert.
Jake:我要转化帮我提谢谢
Jake: I need to convert. Help me carry it, thanks.
Tasha: 帮我提谢谢
Tasha: Help me carry it, thanks.
Shure: 我转化一下
Shure: I'll convert it.
Jake:我转化一下
Jake: I'll convert it.
Shure: go
Shure: Go.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这个不测转化率呢
Jake: Doesn't this measure the conversion rate?
Lucia: 测好了嗯
Lucia: It's measured, yeah.
Jake:测好了哦
Jake: It's measured, oh.
Lucia: 他一一反正刚才的那个是89克
Lucia: The last one was 89 grams anyway.
Jake:哦让我在这操作是吧
Jake: Oh, you want me to operate this, right?
Lucia: 相当于这个
Lucia: Equivalent to this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我看看有没有电啊
Lucia: Let me check if there's power.
Lucia: 他亮起的两道杠是什么意思
Lucia: What do the two bars lighting up mean?
Jake:呃就是他他开了
Jake: Uh, it means it's on.
Lucia: 那他不显示电量吗
Lucia: Doesn't it show the battery level?
Jake:他没有电量显示
Jake: It doesn't have a battery level indicator.
Jake:他这个设计
Jake: This design...
Lucia: 好落后哦
Lucia: It's so outdated.
Jake:他这个设计可能太前卫了
Jake: This design might be too advanced.
Jake:不知道是前卫还是落后
Jake: Not sure if it's advanced or outdated.
Lucia: 不知道确实不知道是前卫还是落后
Lucia: I don't know, really don't know if it's ahead of its time or behind.
Jake:对对他可能是用的电越多
Jake: Right, right, maybe the more electricity it uses,
Jake:他降的就颜色越少
Jake: the less color it shows.
Jake:就是就是往下面掉
Jake: It just drops down.
Lucia: 颜色越少
Lucia: Less color.
Jake:他是一个路
Jake: It's a path.
Jake:基一样的东西有可能
Jake: Like a base or something, maybe.
Lucia: 嗯呃
Lucia: Hmm, uh.
Lucia: 不是就是您的颜色越少的意思
Lucia: No, I mean, by less color you mean...
Jake:这个长度越短对
Jake: The shorter the length, yeah.
Lucia: 还是颜色越浅
Lucia: Or the lighter the color?
Jake:长度越短
Jake: The shorter the length.
Lucia: 长度越短
Lucia: The shorter the length.
Jake:长度越短对
Jake: The shorter the length, yeah.
Lucia: 好让我试试看是不是这么回事啊
Lucia: Alright, let me give it a try and see if that's the case.
Jake:试试试试试试
Jake: Try, try, try.